So now when you were doing stand up and
you started to get in some trouble for
bits, a lot of trouble. A
lot of trouble. Like how much
travel? Yeah, a lot of money.
I spent a lot of money.
Really as long as I lost a lot of sauces,
I lost a lot of lessons because
of jokes. Really. Lawsuits. Yeah.
So like who was suing you? Uh,
the people who fell offended.
So people in the audience,
artists when I make fun of a celebrity,
they would sue you. Yeah,
they can, they can sue you.
They can get money out of all the TV
shows. They can get up politicians.
So who sued you? You know,
I got this, uh, this last,
so they really, uh, put me in trouble.
It was because of a singer. It was,
she was a singer and a kind of a
almost cute my career. He actually did,
that's why I'm here. So No, uh, yeah,
I got into a huge lawsuit and it
looks dumb when you explain, oh,
it's just a singer.
But he became all this talk about freedom
of speech and what comedians can say.
And what they cannot say.
Are you allowed to feel a fandom?
And now there's like law schools talks
about the lawsuit that I had law school
discussions, discussions out cause
okay. Yeah because I made fun.
He was a shitty joke. That's the problem.
You know, it's not because of the losses.
I want to be sued by the good ones
because I don't want to be known by a bad
joke. Right, right. Oh of course.
Yeah. It's just like I was saying,
this will say it's just like you
were meeting, uh, Eddie Murphy,
one of the greatest comedians ever. They
think, oh, there's doctor Doolittle.
You don't want that right now.
This is the same thing with me.
That joke was a shitty joke.
And she was like bragging on TV and
she was like doing a story on TV.
And I was the host of this huge TV show,
like the daily show and like the
daily show meeting, the view.
It was something like that.
And uh,
and in the middle of the things she was
show us there and my friend asked me, oh,
she's pregnant. And do you think
she's still hot? And I said,
she's so hot that I would
fuck her in her baby and
shit, but it was live. It
was like right on time.
Everybody laughed and
there was no problem.
But next week there was this
huge thing because she was like,
her husband was very influential and uh,
her husband was managing run now do,
which was one of the
biggest soccer player ever.
So there was this whole thing,
the TV show lost the sponsors and uh,
and they want to suspend me from the TV
show because the have a joke that I did.
She didn't tell,
they didn't tell me to apologize at first,
but they suspended me. So I
quit the show. They didn't know.
So you just apologize.
And I decided not to apologize because
I felt that after like 10 years,
don't stand there or 12
years doing stand up.
It was important for me to like put my
feet on the ground and say, you know,
if we step back right now,
what am I,
what am I going to do in like a two years?
This is important for all of
us is important for comedy.
So I lost, lost tell us
movies a, so what did they,
what did they rule in the lawsuit?
Like what was the ruling I have friended
her on or honor or the ad was something
like that. She's like, uh,
uh, they, people can sue you.
Just suing is part of the democracy.
It's okay to sue you. But to look,
to lose a lawsuit is,
that's the problem.
I lost like $150,000 or OTC,
but in Brazil was 350,000 high. So, right.
If you're a lawyer and you get $10,000
a month, you get 10,000 hours a month.
So He's, you don't translate
money. So I lost a lot of money,
but the thing has gotten me a
huge headache and uh, he was,
he was bad. It goes bad chest
from that one just for that one.
But you saw other lawsuit?
Yeah.
How also because I did it
like a rape joke and uh,
I got like this women
movement like trying to break,
break into my bar and break my door
of my comedy club. And there was like,
that was a while.
But the discussion was more
important than the problem itself.
I kind of thought it was the discussion
about freedom of speech and that was,
that was huge.
What is freedom of
speech like in Brazil?
Is it the same?
I mean obviously we have the first
amendment. You have the first summit.
Do you have something? We
don't, we don't have that.
They didn't have that in Canada.
We don't have that.
I had Mike Ward on and Canada. Do you
know his story? Yeah, I know he's the guy.
He made a joke about a sick boy.
The boy was still alive years later.
I thought it was.
And you know it was just a bad joke about
this guy is still being alive and can
he get his money back? Cause like,
cause they donated money. It's like,
it's fucked up joke,
but it's supposed to be a fucked up
joker who's doing it in a nightclub
situation where people are drinking,
you say things that are inappropriate
and that's the art form.
He got sued and he's still in
the process of it right now.
There's another case in Vancouver
where these women were heckling, uh,
they were yelling things out during the
show and then the comedian went on stage
and be rated the women and then
the women's sued and won because a,
they were lesbians and he made some
lesbian jokes about them at their own
expense. And so then they took him to
court and they won and they won what?
They want some judgment where he had
to pay them. I want to change Jimmy.
How much was it? I want to say it was
somewhere in the neighborhood of $30,000.
$30,000. Yeah. I went in and for
this gentleman, this comedian, uh,
I think that was a lot of money.
I don't, 40 to 40. $2,000. Yeah,
that's a lot of fucking money
for opening comedian. I mean,
he wasn't a famous guy, so you know,
that might be two years worked for him.
Who knows, you know, of course, of
course, yeah. Lost a lot of money.
Canada's similar count.
Canada does not have freedom of speech
the same way the United States does.
Yeah. The debt. That's why, uh,
I feel what I do comedy here and I feel
that people get uncomfortable about a
joke or two.
That's when I get stressed.
It's like you have the feeder
of saying those things. Yes.
I have this joke that I say it is about
the n word as well. I might have it,
maybe I have to change my,
but I have this young that I do is like,
when I arrived here, someone said to me,
you don't use the n word or
people are gonna kick her ass.
But they never told me what the n
word was. So for the past six months,
I have been avoiding all
wars with the leather.
And the other day a guy came up to
me and said, can I fuck your ass?
And I was like, mm. Maybe in a,
when I say this job is
like I have to set up,
it's crazy because when I first did,
he was like a fucking thing.
Everybody got uncomfortable.
But now I set up as a misunderstanding
because I'm a foreigner and now I'm free
to do everything. Yes, yes. Yeah.
So I kind of, I found the way
you found a way in. Yeah.
So that's, it's crazy.
And I watch you alive and I see a lot
of people here. I saw the other guy,
this guy,
this guy did an interview with you and
he did this show in a college and he did
a joke and people took him out of
State Mesh. Nimesh Patel. Yeah. Yeah.
That's crazy. Because you built
the freedom to do that. Yes.
And now you're discussing the,
if you can or you cannot solely in
colleges though in children today,
and I'm going to call them children,
they do not understand the danger
in suppressing free speech.
And so they think that what they're
doing is by suppressing free speech and
changing the way people communicate.
What they're doing is making
the world a better place.
They think they're signaling the virtue
and making the world a better place at
the same time. But it's just ignorance.
They just don't understand that you can't,
you can't necessarily,
you can't control people.
And to think that by just getting upset
and silencing someone on removing them
from the stage at that ends
the conversation. It doesn't,
it reinforces their position.
It says, okay, look,
I was right about you fucking snowflakes
and you little babies like you,
you can't even understand when things
are uncomfortable that it doesn't
necessarily mean it's negative.
And that like you're like x,
try to put yourself in someone's position.
See what he's saying.
And in the meshes this case, it's
actually kinda funny, first of all,
he's very open minded guy,
very progressive. He's,
he's not in any way a racist.
And his joke was that people
say that being gay is a choice.
And he said, I know it's not a choice
cause I have a friend who's black and gay.
There's no way he would choose both of
those things. And it was just double up.
It was just him being funny. It's a
funny joke. And they were like, cut,
get the fuck off the stage. Like what?
Come on man. You don't think that's funny.
That's crazy.
I mean and it's also coming from an
Indian man who I'm sure is experienced
racism.
So though the whole thing is,
it's very fascinating to see young kids
who are growing up in this PC culture
bubble and you know,
and sometimes people say on this podcast
that we talk about it too much and
maybe their correct.
Maybe sometimes it's annoying if you're
listening to your cubicle and you hear
me talking too much about this,
but it's because it's an issue
that's very dear to my heart.
Cause I understand the dangers of
not being able to communicate freely.
And I also stay understand what happens
when if you suppress free communication,
the people that you're suppressing,
they're going to get more and more angry
and radical and it just makes their
position, they're, they, they,
they feel more justified in there in
perhaps even people who are racist could
perhaps be more racist or people who are
angry about gay people will become more
angry about it if you suppress
their ability to express himself.
That's when borns, those little movements
and Neil Nasi movements, little groups,
little groups on the web, in the deep
web when discussion, it's like when you,
for when it's for beating I think is
that you can forgive them the power that
they didn't have.
I think so.
And I think this is something that we
really just getting to understand now.
You know,
I have,
I've had a few conversations about this
recently with the head of Twitter and
with the an independent journalist Tim
pool last week and I think what people
were just started to kind of understand,
even though everyone's
uncomfortable about this,
is we're still trying to figure this out.
Social media is only 10 plus years old.
This is an incredibly new experience
for us and I don't think everybody knows
exactly how to proceed.
And this idea that you could just band
people and they just banned people for
life. If they say something
that makes people uncomfortable,
if they say an opinion you don't agree
with, banned them for life. And we're,
we're experiencing that right now.
And uh,
we're trying to figure
out what to do and how to,
how to fix this and how to mitigate
it without endorsing people,
harassing people and divorcing
people, uh, you know,
threatening people and giving out their
address and their phone number and
things along those lines. But
it's a process that we're,
we're all going through,
right? It is a learning process for
the, the, the, the whole country.
But the thing that a,
a noise annoys me a little bit is that I,
I leave it in another country and I see
how things are difficult and how much
time I spent explaining to people
what I was doing. And for you guys,
it's like I was having the same problems
that Lenny Bruce was having like a long
time ago. Yes. And a, you
guys built that. Yeah.
To have that discussion.
It's like it is important because
that's the way the war uh,
evolved.
But at the same time he feels old.
It feels old because you understand
the history of it in America. Yeah.
It feels old because you already had that
discussion a long time ago. Yeah. Yeah.
You kinda keep having this conversation
when you think that you'll finally feel
free to say whatever you want now
there's people trying to hold you back.
It's crazy. Well, it's not
really effective. See there's,
there's people that are angry about it.
I mean there is on social media,
there's certainly people that
are being effective with it.
But in stand up comedy,
it's this,
there's blow back and push back.
But it's not very effective.
Like for the top guys, for guys like Dave
Chappelle and you know, Bill Burr, it's,
it actually makes their stand up better
because people are so tired of all this
shit.
They're so tired of PC culture.
They're so tired of being told what they
should and shouldn't think is funny and
what is acceptable and not
acceptable. And you know, there's a,
there's a lot of weird
shit going on right now.